-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
-Hello, we're back on Overtime.
We've got filmmaker
of the HBO documentary,
The Insurrectionist Next Door,
Alexandra Pelosi.
We have New York Times columnist
Bret Stephens,
and we have CNN contributor
and democratic strategist,
-Paul Begala.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
And these are the questions
hot off the press.
I hold in my hand... (LAUGHS)
...one night I should
just do Carnac
and fuck with their minds.
Should Rashida Tal--
Oh, oh, yes. Hmm.
Should Rashida Talib,
who by the way,
still has not acknowledged
that the missile
that killed the hospital
was not an Israeli missile,
still telling the lie.
Be for--
Should she be forced
to take down
the Palestinian flag
flying outside her office.
Yeah, I saw that picture.
Oh, there you have it--
-BRET STEPHENS: No,
the answer is no.
-PAUL BEGALA: No.
Yeah, I mean,
I despise her political views,
but absolutely not.
She's an American.
She can do whatever she wants.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-BILL MAHER: But--
-Okay.
-And I mean, and I--
-you know where I'm coming from.
-But, I mean,
the American Congress.
Has this been done before?
Do other people-- do like the--
I mean, people come
from different countries.
Do they then fly the f--
I mean, there's plenty of people
I'm sure who have
heritage from Mexico.
Do they put the Mexican flag
outside their office?
It's-- It's--
I think voters should make
judgments
about her political choices,
but I think it's the essence
-of a democracy...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
...that you can fly the flags
that you want--
BILL: Where do you--
Where do you stand on this one?
-I'm not touching that.
-BILL: You're not touching that?
-Come on.
-BILL: Oh, you are afraid
-to get cancelled.
-But-- But--
-BRET: What does your mom think?
-Wait, but here's the thing.
I will go into-- I support
the whole concept
of free speech, right?
And one of the main things
I talk about
in my movie is about
when does free speech
become hate speech?
-BILL: Mm-hmm.
-And when do we go after people,
and call it hate speech.
This was where the whole thing
about getting cancelled
comes from.
Like, "I'm afraid to talk
about that
because I don't wanna get
cancelled."
That's-- "People are gonna say
it's hate speech--"
BILL: Well, what-- Okay.
BRET:
Why don't we just call it...
-BILL: Yeah?
-..."shitty speech"?
BILL: Yeah. I'm not--
It's in the eye of the--
Hate speech is a concept
that's always in the eye
of the beholder.
-BILL: I agree.
-PAUL: Hate speech is
speech that I hate.
So, don't say anything
-I disagree with.
-ALEXANDRA PELOSI: But
there's this whole thing
called free speech,
but who cares
if nobody's listening.
We're not listening
to each other, so who cares.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
I've never been in love
with the concept
of looking into people's minds
when they commit crimes.
It's a crime,
you need to pay for it.
If it-- If you committed
the crime, why you did it,
I don't know.
That gets in the crazy kind
of territory of thought crimes--
-BRET: Right.
-Which is--
Which is exactly
where we don't wanna go.
But, yeah. No, I agree.
She can fly the flag anywhere.
But what does it say
about, you know, you're--
It just seems like you're--
The loyalties are
a little too divided--
I agree,
and let the voters of Michigan
draw their conclusions
next year.
I know how I would vote
if I were in her district,
but, absolutely,
I'm gonna stand up for her right
to speak her mind.
Okay, what do you think
of Putin's meeting with Xi,
that's right, Putin of Russia,
and Xi of China.
Boy, these two, they like have
friendship bracelets.
-One says...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
(LAUGHS)
-(CHUCKLES)
-(CHUCKLES) One says,
"Fuck," and the other says,
"America," you know?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Forming a new axis of evil.
Boy, I mean, I've--
You go, but it's weird
because China and Russia were
always at each other's throats.
And Putin has this
sort of fanboy appeal
to the far right
and Republican--
to a lot of Republicans
which I find astonishing
'cause they'll tell you
they hate
the Chinese Communist Party.
Okay, good. I'm with you buddy.
-But they love Putin.
-(BILL CHUCKLING)
By the way,
Putin was meeting with--
with the Sheikh Nasrallah,
the head of Hezbollah.
-Right.
-He is behind
all of the worst things,
and the worst people
in the world...
-And I think this is something--
-...and yet they love him.
something Biden deeply gets
which is that dictators
-by nature unite.
-BILL: Mm-hmm.
Whatever their geopolitical
differences,
they are birds of a feather,
they see themselves
as authoritarians
who wanna destroy the free world
and that's why
it's important to have leaders
in the free world who recognize
what the threat they pose.
Hamas, Iran,
China, Russia, North Korea.
They all have something
in common.
What did Nazi Germany and Japan
really have in common
except "Oh, we're the bad guys."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Like, that's right.
(CHUCKLES) You're right.
That was really--
I guess w-- the plan--
Was there ever even a plan?
We're gonna divide up the world?
We're gonna conquer
each of our halves,
and then we'll--
Then obviously, they would've
turned on each other,
like Hitler turned on Stalin.
It's weird.
Do you think Mitt Romney
is right to blame Fox News,
and right-wing media
for radicalizing the GOP?
Boy, when Mitt Romney becomes...
And he-- You know--
I must say Mitt Romney,
he is who he is.
This is the kind of guy, you--
You know like...
(ALEXANDRA CHUCKLING)
I mean--
He irons his underwear,
and you know he just--
-You can--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I mean,
when he ran for president,
I was unmerciful,
but he was just,
he just being the person
he was born, he was just,
you know, he's Mitt Romney.
But, Alexandra,
I'm sure you saw a lot of people
who were poisoned by Fox News.
I keep referring
to your interview with Bill
because the--
It's the downstream effect.
They're drinking--
We say in Texas,
"The water won't clear up
until you get
the hogs out the creek."
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-Okay? All these people
are drinking all this shit
that Rupert Murdoch,
and the social media companies
are putting in the water, right?
-ALEXANDRA: Yes, absolutely.
-More like that--
-That's how you get elected...
-Texas... (LAUGHS)
...in this country.
You come out
with stuff like that.
But you saw them, you saw
the victims of that poison,
-right?
-Absolutely.
It's really toxic,
and then of course,
it goes even worse
into the political violence
-territory.
-BILL: Yeah.
And I'll tell you this,
he's making fun of me for this,
but I'm saying
I have to be careful
because I don't want a guy
to break into my house
-with a hammer and try
and kill me at night.
-BILL: No, I'm not, that's not--
And I'll tell you something.
I get-- You come look
at my inbox, and you'd be--
-That's not what I--
-You'd be shitting
in your pants
if you saw my inbox.
- I can.
-How could these people want--
They want to kill me
because why? I don't get it.
I get that,
I don't get the cancel part.
-Oh, okay.
-Remember?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-BRET: It's all about--
-about, um...
-BILL: I get the kill part.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-You're right about that.
About Mitt, I think,
I think he's proved himself
to be a great American.
-He voted for impeachment twice.
-BILL: He did. He really did.
Anyone who is willing
to stand up to the assholery...
-BILL: Right.
-...of your own side
deserves a place
in the American pantheon.
BILL: And there's a few of them,
-Liz Cheney.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
There's a few of them
where they know
there was a bridge too far.
I hear a lot, I really do
from Republicans on the hill
about their personal safety.
One of the reasons
they don't want to break
with the kooks is
their personal security.
Mitt Romney, it's been reported,
spends 5000 dollars a day
on security for himself
and his family.
He's a very wealthy man,
but most members are not wealthy
and there is an honest
fear factor that is real
and legitimate
that is causing a lot of these
Republicans to cower.
Okay, what does the panel think
of Gavin Newsom's trip
to Israel and China?
Is he setting himself up
for a presidential run?
I mean. (LAUGHS)
It does kind of look like
he's running to be the stand-in,
in ca-- I'm not saying
I'm wishing for something
-to happen to Biden,
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
but is a little "Prince Charles
when the mother was still alive"
-feeling to--
-(CROWD LAUGHING)
-BILL: No?
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
And he went to the debate--
The Republican debate--
He went to the last Republican
debate with Joe Biden's blessing
and carried the torch for Biden
and the Democrats,
-I thought he did a great job.
-BILL: And you don't think
he'd be a better candidate
than Biden?
-Not better than Biden
but one day...
-BILL: Really?
...he'll probably run
and that'll be great.
Okay, all right.
Thank you, everybody.
-We appreciate your patience.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
We'll see you next week.